[Music]
john joins us up first this hour in
grand rapids john welcome to the show
hey how you doing i'm doing great how
are you
i am overwhelmed but still way better
than what i should ever be that's a
beautiful task
let me help you get well today how's
that
that sounds absolutely fantabulous um
what's going on in your
situation breakdown um both my wife and
i are 20.
my wife is six months pregnant um guru
and of course about three
months um
we had
so about three months ago we started to
remodel the house with
about with money that we had above and
beyond our emergency fund well since
then we've had
about seven to eight thousand dollars
worth of unexpected bills come up and i
got a
new truck to me and i was going to sell
my old one
i should have been able to make a couple
grand and i did that i was they speak
directly on your phone for me john
you're cutting in and out
isn't this a little bit better yes
okay okay so you've got a new to you
truck
yeah all right that's where you left off
okay um paid six grand for it my
old one should have been able to sell
for eight
and
cannot sell it
and that was
the stupid part was that was supposed to
be our emergency fund with that i was
expecting a quick foot
on my old truck quick sell
but it's not selling and we have
absolutely no
money now in our uh
in our savings because of that and uh my
wife informed me this morning that she
needed tires like
yesterday and so i checked it out and we
had to get herself a brand new set of
tires and
um
work right now is a little bit rocky i
just had my three month enter three
month meeting
and it did not go too hot and so i'm
scared to take over time
okay so let me recap here how much debt
do you guys currently have
um
just like 500 bucks from the tires from
this morning okay do you put those on a
credit card
yeah i did how much money do you have in
the bank
um
nickel and diming everything probably
about there um
we'll get rid of that little bit of debt
um by friday tomorrow my paycheck is
sitting
and uh
friday my wife is
okay so right now how much money do you
have in the bank
not counting the 500 credit card
that's about it okay so pretty much zero
dollars to your name currently until
this paycheck hits yeah
and you drain the emergency fund uh to
pay for these random emergencies plus
you paid for the truck with the
emergency fund hoping you'd flip the
other one
yeah okay so why can't you sell this
other truck that's worth eight thousand
i have no idea i have it listed for
seven and no there's absolutely no
interest where's enlisted
um i have it on 26 different groups on
facebook and facebook marketplace okay
have you checked with some of these
companies like carvana or room or local
dealerships to see what they would buy
it for
um
not a whole lot
there's
pretty much around me there's just a
whole bunch of little mom and pop
places um
i'm going to keep pushing to sell this
truck asap because right now it's just
sitting there right you have two trucks
yeah correct yeah
that's my aim at all it hasn't been on
the road in three weeks is there
anything wrong with the truck are the
photos good
what do you think is wrong with it
why it's not selling just
your typical cosmetic okay what's your
household income
uh right around 55
okay
and your wife is currently working
correct will she work outside the home
once baby's here
um yeah she will she will take the first
little
bit
and stay home with the baby but she
she loves what she does too much she
said she doesn't think that she can stay
home so she'll go back to work
after maternity leave
correct okay well i know life has been
punching you in the face man but the
good news is you're you're not that far
in the hole you're 500 in debt when
these paychecks hit you'll be able to
pay that off and then your focus is
going to be saving up for this baby
so i want you to start working on that
fully funded emergency fund slash baby
fund and once baby is here and safe then
we can move on to our other goals but a1
in the next three months is to sell this
truck work your tail off to stack up as
much money as possible would that give
you some peace of mind and let you
breathe a little easier
well my my only concern with
um always taking overtime
is i'm already kind of rocky here with
this job so rocky is in what
i just had my three month interview last
week or sorry not interview review and
it was not too hot so you're basically
on a probationary type
period right now
yeah correct so they feel like you're
not performing at the level you should
be
correct what kind of work are you doing
construction okay
are there other construction jobs out
there that would pay equal or more
if this thing fell through
the answer is yes it was a trick
question john
there are some is not a whole lot um
most people around here they've all
worked with each other the previous guy
that i worked with everyone knew that i
worked with them and they wouldn't even
return my phone calls because they
wanted to honor my previous employer
okay well i'm gonna do what i can to not
biff this job here and then on top of
that i'm gonna go find other side
hustles maybe outside of construction
maybe it's handyman work i don't know
what your skill set is but find
something that can pay you know 20 25
bucks an hour in this market i think
that's really reasonable and for the
next this is temporary remember but for
the next three months your job is to
stack up as much money as possible avoid
going into debt because once this 500
bucks is gone you're in baby step three
working on the emergency fund and kind
of taking this pause to go we gotta
stack up money for this baby make sure
mom and baby are healthy and then we can
take a deep breath and figure out what
life looks like
yeah but right now there's no time for
excuses there's no time for a well i
don't know if there's dude you've got to
be hustling grinding because you're
about to be a dad and i want you to be
able to take care of your family and do
it with some dignity
so that's my a1 if i'm in your shoes i
feel the pressure man i'm not trying to
say this is going to be easy but for 90
days if you can just dial in and focus
and i want to help you get there i'm
going to gift you one year of ramsay
plus so hang on the line austin will
pick up it includes financial peace
university it includes every dollar
premium our budgeting tool
that will give you some peace of mind
some control over where your money's
going and some next steps that's what i
want for you good luck with the baby
hope for everything to go smoothly
healthy and happy for you all
and thanks for the call man this is the
ramsay show